RUSSIAN GOVERNOR ELEMENT TO HELP
HIS FATHER'S CAMPAIGN.
ANOTHER FIGURE IS ACCUSED OF
SHARING INFORMATION WITH AN
ASSOCIATE WHO MAY HAVE TIES TO
RUSSIAN INTELLIGENCE.
CATHERINE HAS MORE ON THAT.
NEW TROUBLE FOR PAUL MANAFORT
AND THE UNUSUAL WAY WE FOUND OUT
ABOUT IT.
>> A GLITCH IN THE COURT FILING
ALLOWED THE REDACTED PORTIONS TO
BE READ.
THE SPECIAL COUNSEL SAID PAUL
MANAFORT REACHED OUT TO A
BUSINESS ASSOCIATE WHO IS
DESCRIBED AS A RUSSIAN POLITICAL
CONSULTANT.
WHO DENIED TIES TO RUSSIAN
INTELLIGENCE.
TODAY'S COURT FILINGS RESPOND TO
SPECIAL COUNSEL ALLEGATIONS THAT
THE FORMER TRUMP CAMPAIGN CHAIR
MAN LIED TO FEDERAL
INVESTIGATORS.
MANAFORT'S LAWYERS REPORT THEIR
CLIENT IS SUFFERING FROM
DEPRESSION AND ANXIETY AND IS
USING A WHEELCHAIR.
THEY SAID MANAFORT OFTEN DOESN'T
HAVE THE CHANCE TO REVIEW
RECORDS BEFORE MEETING ABOUT
SPECIAL COUNSEL INVESTIGATORS.
MISTAKES AND FAILED RECOLLECTION
ARE COMMON.
THERE IS NO PATTERN TO HIS
MISREPRESENTATION.
NO SPECIFIC CRIME IS IDENTIFIED.
THE DEFENSE LAWYERS ARE NOT
ASKING FOR AN IMMEDIATE HEARING.
THEY SAID SPECIAL COUNSEL CLAIMS